I have one of my favorite Talk of the
tables because it is one of my favorite
shows and we got one of the Stars I'm
talking about the hit CBS show Ghost and
the star is utkarsh abud car he plays
Jay there's Jay on the right all right
now the show's a little hard to explain
but I'm gonna do my best in the show
okay he and his wife Sam move into an
old estate and open up a bed and
breakfast there little do they know
however that there are ghosts already in
the bed and breakfast so after Sam
suffers a near-death accident she hits
her head suddenly she can now see and
talk to all the ghosts in the bed and
breakfast they include a hippie there's
a Wall Street bro there's a woman from
the beginning of the 20th century
everybody through all time was died on
the property is there almost everybody
but Jay who I'm about to introduce
the clip from an upcoming episode take a
look oh boy so were you just shooting
around no I played pickup and I met some
really cool locals and they found out
that we run the Woodstone BNB and they
were so into it are we like local
celebrities hey so listen Micah
mentioned that they might want to come
over tomorrow and watch the game oh Mike
is kind of like their leader the leader
uh boss they work together I don't know
anyway would that be cool well it sounds
to me like somebody made some friends
good for you for putting yourself out
there come on babe it's not that big of
a deal yeah Woody was Mom no it's just
it's been harder on Jay we both left our
friends in the city but I have all you
guys to talk to and I know that
sometimes he must feel left out yeah
like now could be one of those times
oh sorry I just
exactly
and Garf joins us now uh and you really
are a fan too I am a huge fan my whole
family yes we accosted you my wife and I
my whole family's watched every episode
of season one we're very excited about
season two
um but it is a hard show to explain when
I tell people how excited I am they say
what's it about and then I kind of
stumble so how do you do it it's like a
it's a family comedy it's a workplace
comedy about a bunch of ghosts trying to
learn how to live and uh so they're
living current times and they live in
yeah yeah we got a Boy Scout thank God
they're all up here Viking We Got a Boy
Scout we got a a baroness and there are
basically a bunch of different people
from different walks of life who are all
forced to live in this house together
and now luckily there's these two humans
who uh can sort of help them work
through all their historical issues so
it's for everybody I mean it's really is
yes I'm late to the ghost party because
I thought when I heard the premise I
went mad Tony was always raving about I
went you and I both Gail
I don't know about this but did you
think when you read it I just thought
how could this possibly be good but it's
so good I was like Gail I got kids the
schools are expensive let me get on that
sitcom money but but no I think it was
it's a beautiful premise and it's really
funny and I watched the BBC version and
I was really tickled I mean it's it's
this it's it's really nice and it's a
diverse cast and it's really cool that
Rose and I get to play opposite each
other and um it's well written very well
job acting everybody does I think it's
crazy what's so great about it is like
all the comedy that you're used to
seeing in a sitcom is instead jokes
between people who are spread out across
centuries so you got this like weird
historical Dimension that makes it so
good and some of these characters can
say things that uh modern characters
could not but not yes yeah because you
can't cancel them exactly right I'm
surprised they did surprises are safe
for TV to be honest with you this is
something that's on the line for CBS I
think we're pushing the arms people
really like it I was really excited for
your character because at the end of the
last season yes your character who
cannot see the ghost yeah uh had a fall
and I thought maybe you'd be able to see
him me too did you think that too page
one I texted the Joe's our show Runners
and I was like oh you guys did it thank
you so much and then page two was just
full of expletives I was like you mother
how dare feathers yes hopefully let's
see if we got a season three maybe
there's still a chance you're gonna get
a season three so I'm curious
um do you believe in ghosts uh I believe
in better angels I think our Spirits I
think that our ancestors are here
they're guiding us if we allow them to
but in terms of like Insidious and
malevolent spirits and stuff like that
that's uh nah I'm okay with all that I
feel you on that but look at all the
stuff you get to do because you did
never have I ever still the Dropout the
Dropout Tick Tick boom right and so
you're juggling TV and movie projects it
so you're very busy yeah this is good
for your wife and your kids yeah well we
have a good time and they support me
very much my wife now speaking of
supporting you do we have pictures of uh
of the of the children uh in ghost
costumes from the show yeah do we yeah
they are all right tell us about this
picture took them to rom-com right the
Comic-Con comic concept but yeah we
could put him in a rom-com too that
that's boomy not that kind of show he's
a product of a rom-comm
that's tiare my daughter she dressed up
as flower and boomi dressed up as Trevor
uh for Comic-Con and it was just it was
amazing they we love to support each
other and get dressed up but you're also
a freestyle rapper I do I do do some
raps Nate knows how to do that too so be
careful I'll do a little something what
you got what you got well you know what
we had a Broadway run just a block away
at the booth theater freestyle Love
Supreme yes I love that I love that it's
coming to Vegas November and Gail you
should come see me there yeah I saw you
well listen I I got a little something
for you okay it's a little something
like you want me to give you a beat no
that's cool
I just tell people like this you better
tune in because if you don't that's just
crazy I mean I love ghosts for me it's
the show Casper than Patrick Swayze hey
I mean the show is hilarious it'll crack
you up like a broken jar I mean these
spirits will touch your soul just like a
open bar just a little something a
little
something
wherever you are this dude's got your
number right this dude's coming for you
I'm a big fan I'm a big fan of freestyle
Supreme I'm a big fan of you I got you
what do you got live TV okay here we
come in oh yes without a warning I came
to spit it with Tony on CBS Morning hey
my name is UGK I'm known for the flows I
came to push the show called ghost
Thursdays 8 30 after young Sheldon uh
what you smelling all right
hey let me tell you something about
being on two hours of sleep
and can I say
sued really cute
thank you Nate this
to me that's great I said it was ombre
and I was like I think she means tie-dye
but
I mean ombre it is
amazing people need to check it out you
can watch ghosts on CBS also Paramount
plus if you watch it on TV it's on at 8
30 7 30 Central right here again CBS or
any old time you want on Paramount Plus